hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and I would love to be your neighbor
tonight I saw won't you be my neighbor
which is the Mister Rogers
documentary film there wasn't much
coming out this week there was a weird
action film and something of if there
wasn't a lot happening this week so I
was thinking maybe for like the shock
value I'd see gaudy or goatee whatever I
have no idea who he is and then I was
twitching and someone was like hey why
don't you watch the mr. Rogers
documentary because it's gonna be
amazing and uplifting so I did and it
was amazing and it was uplifting alright
I got my sweater on I could talk about
mr. Rogers so much conflict that's not
being resolved and there's so so many
things that are happening right now that
what regardless of what you believe what
side you're on which is the worst but
regardless of all of that nothing's
being resolved in a nice peaceful way
right buddy
everyone just feels really just sad and
and you know just they're hitting a wall
and I feel that super hard right now and
I know that I could does as well and I
feel like this movie was so important
for me to see it's just uplifting and
there's not enough of that content out
there right now at all so I grew up with
mr. Rogers in syndication
he wasn't on air I don't think when I
watched him was he on air in the 90s I
don't know any facts you guys he's got
such a love language to children in a
way that translates to adults as well
obviously because my the theater I was
at was just full of adults I've never
seen another entertainer who could speak
so simply and so open and vulnerable Eve
that was very accessible for children
but also touched adults there's so much
beautiful comedy out there there's so
much beautiful like all these superhero
movies like beautiful violence that we
all love and beautiful you know drama
and beautiful just like very you know
trash TV that we all love to like
partake in sometimes and there's so much
and he was not a fan of those things
there's nothing as simple and effective
and there never will be as his show I
don't think this whole episode is just
gonna be me just being like I love him
and I cried throughout the whole and I
wasn't alone the entire theater behind
me was sniffling and wiping their eyes
and was so affected by just the simple
sentiments that he he shared with with
most people most people want goodness
and kindness and graciousness and
honesty and truth and and and so to see
someone else living that way cuz I got a
lot of people you know me I don't feel
like I lived that way as much as I would
like to but seeing someone just live
that way just unashamed like just living
their very truth is so inspiring and
beautiful and you guys this was so
impactful for me I needed it too I've
been sad but you know it just like
needing an uplifting experience in film
and this was absolutely that he was so
good at talking to children and he he
kind of retained this imagination from
childhood you find out because he was
very sick throughout his childhood he
was also bullied throughout his
childhood which I think a lot of people
identify with whether it's sickness like
scarlet fever and and and a load of
other things I identify with that with
like I got type 1 diabetes at very young
age and I had a lot of sicknesses
growing up and also was bullied I think
a lot of people identify with that
really like with through autism and a
lot of people identify with that with
there's so much out there that you feel
bullied by and you feel like left behind
with and so that's just right off the
bat such a connector there and that he
was able to use
imagination to like create friends and
create stories and characters as a kid
and he held onto that into adulthood is
it's it's so cool a table right that's
something that I see and I'm like oh
yeah sing I feel about I totally get
that and I totally I'm on the same page
with you and I'm on the same page with
him because he allows every one every
single person to be on the same page
with him he's not above anyone and he
would be so welcoming of everyone I
wrote down that he was just the absolute
best communicator with children and and
then I was I came back later after
writing a few pages of notes sounds like
actually it wasn't his children it was
just like everyone it's just children
are so open to these like they're it's a
simple lesson like a lot of people
watched his show and it really irked him
honestly that people weren't getting his
show they were thinking oh it's like a
simple it's like very like kitschy it's
very like 50s very simple kind of here's
the lesson of the day and then it didn't
take a lot of work and one thing he said
is that don't let anyone think that this
was easy for me it was very difficult
for me was very difficult for him to
write these scripts and he thought you
know judge didn't pressure like everyone
does but I think the simpleness was so
easy for children to take in but it's
something that everyone needs to hear
like everyone and it's such good
communication for every like age bracket
also Netflix can we just get that shit
home please on Netflix please we have
Bob Ross thank thank everything but we
need Bob and repeat mr. Rogers please I
wrote a bunch of quotes down but one of
them that really stuck with me is I
don't think children can grow unless
they're accepted as they are exactly as
they are why are there more shows like
that like expressing that that's the
most important thing that you need to
hear as a kid and it got him in trouble
later on people were like now this whole
generation of kids has grown up and they
all think they're special and they're
not and it's mr. Rogers fault he meant
by that that you don't have to do
anything spectacular you don't have to
do like you know you
the president you don't have to be
Beyonce
to have love in your life and if it's as
simple as that like you just if you live
a normal life if you're a lovely person
if you're kind then you deserve love
that's what he meant by that and and so
it's hilarious that people kind of got
on this case I so love that they didn't
portrayed him as a perfect man they
mostly did like 90% of the way the actor
that played the cop on the show was gay
and is gay and at first he wasn't okay
with that not that he wasn't okay with
it he didn't like fire him but he was
like you can't go to the gay clubs it
can't be like put out we'll lose our
funding so he got married to a woman
then they divorced because that's just
not how that works and then a bunch he
came around to it and in the interview
they asked his wife mr. Rogers why like
oh and like you guys have a lot of gay
friends and she's like oh heavens yes
like it was just it was beautiful that
like everyone has things and like you
learn and you come around and and and
you just love people it's just about
people you know he has a quote that says
feelings are mentionable and manageable
which I just started crying at because
thinking that feelings aren't and that
you can't mention your feelings he grew
up feeling like he couldn't talk about
anger a lot that really got me and
especially telling like little boys that
feelings are mentionable is so sweet my
god this entire episode is just like a
therapy session for me I wrote I've yeah
honestly speaking of I wrote I'm not as
kind and honest and genuine as I can be
and it's like I used to be and I feel
just like so like hardened over from
from like the internet like what a state
with anger so dumb you see at the end of
his life he's really angered by the lack
of good in the world there's way more
television happening it's like the
dawning of the Internet
he died in 2003 and so he was really
angered by the lack of good that he was
seeing the world was less wholesome or
at least there was an avenue for people
who weren't wholesome to really just
like let everyone know about it I also
feel that
I also feel that and I think everyone
does more so than that anger that I saw
that he was feeling I took the love hue
still gave out and like was still so
open about and was still so giving of
everything he had again I just I so
recommend this movie this wasn't like a
review at all it was just me having
therapy for myself I just had the best
time I walked into the theater I was so
tired I was gonna film tomorrow I was
just gonna come home and sleep but I got
home I was just so happy and thankful
and grateful and ready to to be lovely
and love people and what a great thing
to take from something versus like other
films that I love like hereditary I just
saw but I did not leave that theater
feeling like I want to love people I
felt like I need to just like go to a
therapy session and so it's something
that I don't feel you you take from a
lot of content anymore that it's just
like pure positive joy I don't know I
don't know if that makes sense
I don't know if any of this has made
sense but I had such a good time
watching this I super recommend it and I
just love you all and I hope you have a
great night and I will see you next week
just as joyful all right bye guys
[Music]